- [Voiceover] So we have
negative 30x to the fifth
is equal to negative 10x
to the third, times F.
And I encourage you to pause this video
and see if you can figure
out what F is going to be.
Well, the way that we can tackle it,
we could just isolate the F
on the right-hand side here
if we divide by negative 10x to the third.
So we might say, well, we want to divide
this side by negative 10x to the third,
but if we want the equality to be true,
if we want the left side
to stay being the same
as the right side,
whatever we do with the right side
we have to do to the left side as well.
So we have to divide the left side
by negative 10x to the third.
And then what does that leave us with?
Well, on the right-hand side, up top
we're multiplying by
negative 10x to the third,
and then we're dividing by
well, multiplying by something
and then dividing by that same thing
is the same thing as
just multiplying by one,
or one way to think about
it, they just cancel out.
So we are just going to be left with an F.
We're going to be left an
F on the right-hand side.
And there's the whole point,
we wanted to solve for F.
And on the left-hand side,
we can first look at the coefficients.
We could say negative 30 divided by,
negative 30 divided by negative 10
is positive three.
So that's going to be three.
And then x to the fifth power
divided by x to the third power,
well that's going to be x-squared,
x-squared.
You could either think of
it in terms of our exponent
properties, we would
subtract these two exponents,
x to the five minus
three, which is x-squared
or you could say up on top that's
x times x times x times x times x.
Did I say that right? Five x's.
You could do it as x,
let me do to that, on top,
you have x to the fifth which is this.
I also like to remind myself
why the exponent properties even work.
And then on the denominator,
on the denominator you have
x times x times x
and these three x's are going to cancel
and you're just going to
be left with x times x
which is just x-squared.
So you get F is equal to three x-squared
so you could write,
we could write that
negative 30x to the fifth
is equal to,
is equal to the
negative 10x to the third
times F and now we know that F
is three x-squared.
Three x-squared.
And so another way to
describe what's going on
in this equation, we could say that
negative 30x to the fifth
is divisible by either one
of these factors.
That negative 30x to the
fifth is divisible by
negative 10x to the third
or we could say negative 30x to the fifth
is divisible by three x-squared
or we could say that three x-squared
is a factor of negative 30x to the fifth.
And the way that we can
make these claims about
factor and divisibility
is we're dealing with
non-fractional coefficients
right over here
and we're also dealing with
non-fractional exponents
right over here
so that's why we're saying,
hey, these are factors,
this yellow thing and this magenta thing,
factors of this blue thing
or this blue thing is divisible
by either one of these.